[Musique]
c'est énorme quand tu fais ça je te jure
qu'il faut que tu arrêtes de faire cette
rupture mais moi j'aime bien ta cabaret
elle va décoller quant à 13% mais quand
arrêtera de dire trois mots qui sont
super civile explique peut-être que
je t'aime trop ses intrigues du je suis
très content d'être avec mon rétroviseur
enfin on peut faire une photo avec moi
je décroche pas la survie sur mesure
donc je tremble un peu trop occupés nous
trois on fait tout ça dérange pas merci
ça va
aller dans quoi ouais j'habite juste à
côté là de rue ah ouais quand je t'ai
envoyé par message sur un statut m'a
jamais répondu ça quand on vend encore
manon la douceur tout attaché aux jeunes
et à les voir tout en noir ok cool on
sait déjà on est proche est à dire en
faisant plusieurs fois dit comme ça à
fond méchant hyper bon bah merci c'est
quoi c'est quoi ton parfois tenait les
cif ah ok
on peut en faire une je te fais un bisou
ce jour manon a non vie des bonnes donc
on va s'arrêter là allez allez allez
vous
attendre des lustres justement tu fais
quoi excusez-moi j'ai souvent une
question s'est désolé j'ai adoré la
flamme mec dedans tellement drôle
jonathan c'est un truc de ouf du coup je
voulais savoir si à une saison 2 prévu
ouais c'est vrai ouais ça va être très
bien [ __ ] il est tellement drôle
versez jonathan
moi je suis dans la saison 2
[Musique]